judging by Twitter alone it seems like
all that you and Nick do is make puzzle
yes it's like it's what you do all the
time yeah make puzzles yeah we sit and
do jigsaw puzzles and just do a ton of
blow yeah we do I like that no we don't
know um but we do puzzles and we listen
to audiobooks it's really scintillating
at our house also the puzzles you pick
these really straight you blue yeah the
prerequisite is to try to find like
really the stupidest puzzles that that
we pasta picking crazy scenes yeah it
seems really lame girls and then we you
know they're like a thousand-piece
puzzle so there might be a lame picture
of it takes us forever to do right and
so we do them and then we take pictures
and we put them on Twitter and it's one
of the rules that you guys are trying to
emulate the scene that's in the puzzle
is that what you're trying to do you're
trying to act it out well yeah it
depends on the puzzle but oftentimes we
will try to act out the subject matter
of the puzzle to whatever degree is
possible we have first of all what's
show one there's there there's I like
that Nick is the wolf editorials
see behind me on the couch background
yeah that little dog peeking over he's
the other wolf okay let's move on to the
next one I'm just curious
oh very arduous also like I'm gonna
start out with our shirts off but how
does it evolve we were like wait a
minute yeah you got a really good part
all right blossom that's Spring Blossom
look Nick is being spring blossom it was
that was during the summer so shirtless
puzzling was sort of David David Kerr
and yeah there was a warm breeze
a-blowin I'm going to I enter admit I
had to admit that I ragging right my my
wife my wife lies and I went to your
house to hang with you guys and I didn't
know anything about this yeah blow and
and and so we were hanging on it house
we show up and you had a puzzle out and
I didn't know anything about this and
then you had you made Nick and I pose I
believe we took a photo I don't know Who
am I I don't know you're the lion I'm
the lion the lamb or you possibly are
the lion and he's the little wait I
thought I was Jesus Jesus he's using it
no you're Jesus give me a little line
yeah
he's the little boy yeah it is called
the line in the lamb not Jesus of a
little boy so I and when you invite
someone over to your house it's only
customary to let them be Jesus yeah yeah
yeah that's just being polite right
right yeah but you are the only uh
you're the only guest star of our
puzzles thus far so all right you know
just keep it that way
yeah phones all over town or ringing
right now
let me in on one of those puzzles hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please